Buongiorno a tutti e grazie io Fanno un
po' controcorrente e chiederei a tutti
di mettere via i cellulari e di
concentrarci su questo momento ma
capisco anche l'esigenza di
comunicazione quindi poi teniamo
l'equilibrio e ringrazio anche i
precedenti speaker soprattutto quello
che è stato prima di me perché mi ha
dato un bel assist e vi renderete conto
Spero vi lascio questa sfida di come
quello che sto per dirvi sia collegato
sicuramente ai primi due speech e spero
anche a tutti gli altri allora Tutto è
cominciato facendo il coach anzi molto
prima è sempre stato dentro di me come
lo è in tutti noi ma facendo il suocero
ho iniziato a comprendere di cosa sto
parlando sto parlando di trovare il
nostro scopo nella vita
quella che per i più moderni innovatori
si chiama appunto purpose Ma che per
tutti da sempre ha un nome che dovremmo
riportare nella nostra vita immagino per
tutti i Laika
la vocazione la nostra chiamata la
vocazione è quello che siamo destinati a
fare anche se oggi scopriremo che il
fare è solo una naturale conseguenza
dell'essere e nell'essere non c'è
nessuno scopo la vocazione è quello che
ci viene naturale ma questo non
significa che la strada sia in discesa e
senza ostacoli
Il nostro scopo nella vita Cominciamo
con tre messaggi non c'è nessuno scopo
nella vita al di là di vivere messaggio
numero 2 il nostro vero scopo è quello
di realizzare la vita come esistenza
eterna 3 questa esistenza eterna è puro
amore e noi possiamo vivere di questo
Puro amore questo messaggio che ho
articolato in tre punti in realtà solo
uno e uno qui lo dico con caratteri e
cuore maiuscoli perché mi riferisco a
quell'uno al quale oggi non diamo nessun
nome ma che per chi lo vede è amore
infinito energia coscienza quella
coscienza che muove tutto che è in tutto
che contiene tutto e che nulla può
contenere
e prima di andare avanti Vorrei fare una
premessa oggi non sono su un palco non
vi sto insegnando Niente sono anch'io
nel mio cammino nel mio viaggio e ogni
persona ha la propria storia ogni storia
la sua soluzione e tutte meritano il
nostro rispetto con passione e
compressione
Ripartiamo dal coaching Anche se oggi
siamo tutti un po' coach chi lo fa
veramente per professione è brava ad
aiutare gli altri nel fare chiarezza sul
Come raggiungere i propri obiettivi in
modo che ognuno capisca come arrivarci
infatti a me non piace dire che un coach
ti fa raggiungere gli obiettivi
preferisco dire che ti aiuta ad auto
eliminare quei condizionamenti che ti
impediscono di vedere attenzione su
questo di vedere cosa
di vedere se quello che vogliamo è
quello di cui abbiamo veramente bisogno
perché quello che vogliamo spesso è
frutto di illusioni mentre quello di cui
abbiamo bisogno è molto più vicino alla
nostra vera natura a quello che siamo e
noi siamo questo uno questo amore questo
amore che sostiene tutto e che non ha
bisogno di nulla per sostenersi e se vi
sembra una sciocchezza è perché tutti
noi in modo automatico pensiamo
all'amore terreno che è fatto di mente
di ormoni di attrazione
a volte fatto anche di aspettative di
odio tra questi due amori c'è un
collegamento che fra poco vedremo
ovviamente ma qui stiamo parlando di
un'altra sostanza E allora come facciamo
a scoprire chi siamo questo uno questo
amore quello di cui abbiamo veramente
bisogno
Come facciamo a mettere al primo posto
chi siamo per goderci la vita invece di
goderci la vita per scoprire chi siamo
i modi non sono tanti Chi di voi non ha
mai fatto un corso di meditazione stile
di vita o nell'ambito lavorativo magari
leadership crescita personale Se vi va
alzate la mano
tantissimi Immagino Ok adesso vediamo
quanti rimangono con la mano alzata Chi
di voi poi in realtà non l'avete alzata
in tanti ma lo speaker così Chi di voi
poi riesce a mantenere questo stato
esistenziale Questa consapevolezza Come
è stata esistenziale in ogni momento
della giornata
Ok molti meno
tutti questi insegnamenti fantastici i
miei preferiti sono lo stile di vita e
la meditazione
ma c'è un grande ma
Non tutto funziona per tutti allo stesso
modo perché in noi a livello del nostro
sistema nervoso c'è stampato un sottile
ma potente messaggio che ci fa percepire
la vita e la sicurezza della nostra vita
in un determinato modo persino la
meditazione che il metodo universale
riconosciuto per scoprire questo amore
il nostro sé non è praticata da tutti
allo stesso modo riassumendo
noi percepiamo il mondo attraverso i
sensi questi sensi creano noi delle
risposte o delle reazioni chimiche
fisiologiche ormonali di vario tipo
questo crea in noi le emozioni le
emozioni hanno una base chimica questo
crea il modo in cui pensiamo quello che
vogliamo quello che desideriamo è molto
di quello che facciamo questo crea
spesso quasi sempre la nostra identità e
la maggior parte di noi
passerà il proprio tempo a cercare di
cambiare il mondo fuori
e tutta questa cosa è molto simpatica
perché ha a che fare con il passato e mi
riferisco per chi le vede per chi ci
crede alle Vite Passate ma per tutti può
valere questo alla nostra memoria da
quando siamo bambini al nostro
apprendimento ma soprattutto
l'apprendimento del nostro sistema della
vita dell'evoluzione in sei milioni di
anni perché noi manteniamo quei
caratteri di risposta di reazione di
difesa e di sopravvivenza di evoluzione
che la vita ha da sempre la vita
naturale
E allora vi chiedo
come facciamo
ovunque in tutti i canali di
comunicazione a dirci che dobbiamo
vivere nel presente quando la maggior
parte non so quantificare quanti non
voglio sparare numeri a caso lo
stabilite voi ognuno per sé se la
maggior parte delle nostre azioni sono
un frutto una conseguenza del passato
come facciamo
a sapere chi siamo se la nostra identità
è stata costruita in risposta al mondo
fuori
Come facciamo a sapere quello di cui
abbiamo bisogno
se queste reazioni queste risposte a
volte sono più veloci o indipendenti
dalla nostra ragione questa nostra
ragione che è quel quella possibilità in
più che abbiamo rispetto agli altri
esseri viventi
la spiritualità Anche se purtroppo non
da queste parti ci insegnano una cosa
importantissima
che il nostro sistema nervoso non è
fatto per dirci con chi siamo ma è fatto
per dirci come Stiamo come stiamo E chi
siamo sono due cose diverse ma con
legate se vogliamo il come stiamo
arriviamo a scoprire chi siamo questo
uno questa vita questo amore ma il
confondere nella nostra quotidianità E
chi siamo con il come stiamo e quello
che ci ha portato che ci porta a fare
degli errori
ed è per questo che iogananda un
grandissimo Io oggi un grandissimo Santo
spero che lo conosciate diceva che la
vera religione è il nostro sistema
nervoso
E allora vi chiedo
Ma se tutto questo meccanismo sembra
portarci fuori
lontano da chi siamo è forse sbagliato
No
Il punto è che noi da sempre abbiamo
iniziato a confondere
le esperienze che per loro natura
nascono si trasformano e muoiono con la
vita che è esistente eterna e puro amore
in ogni momento il nostro sistema Cerca
connessione Cerca questo amore Fateci
caso magari sta succedendo a voi anche
adesso
io lo noto quando sono in un locale dove
ci sono tanti giovani e tanti
adolescenti in ogni momento il nostro
sguardo sta cercando qualcosa fuori
quando non lo trova fuori lo cerca nel
cellulare perché Perché non è abituato a
cercare la risposta dentro
se noi cerchiamo il nostro scopo nella
vita fuori che siano oggetti lavoro
relazioni non lo troveremo mai perché
queste cose sono esperienze che nascono
si trasformano cambiano muoiono
io Tra pochissimi giorni diventerò papà
quindi mi rendo conto del peso di quello
che sto dicendo quando lo provavo a casa
mi scendevano anche le lacrime
perché noi non possiamo trovare il
nostro scopo nella vita neanche nelle
altre persone ma allora dov'è che c'è
questo amore l'amore è nel supportare le
altre persone nel supportarci a vicenda
nell'esprimere questo scopo ognuno di
noi lo può fare
nell'esprimere e scoprire quello che
siamo questa Eternità questo amore
Questa divinità
e l'amore allora in questo che cos'è
l'amore è una cornice nella quale tutto
questo può emergere l'amore quello
strumento che ci insegna a rispondere
alla vita l'amore è quell'energia con la
batteria infinita che ci aiuta a
trasformare il come stiamo in chi siamo
per rendere tutto uno
per fare quello che oggi chiamiamo
bioking perché
in ogni esperienza c'è il messaggio
dell'esistenza in ogni domanda c'è già
la risposta in ognuno di noi c'è questo
seme di di questo uno di questo amore
che aspetta di fiorire in tutto questo
non c'è niente di individuale perché
come dicono tutte le
fedile spiritualità le filosofie del
mondo
ogni nostra azione ogni nostro desiderio
tutto Dovrebbe essere rivolto a servire
questo uno a servire questo amore perché
in realtà stiamo esprimendo e scoprendo
quello che siamo in questo la nostra
individualità qui ci colleghiamo al
discorso del talento la nostra
individualità Dove la lasciamo tutto il
nostro sistema dove lo lasciamo di nuovo
c'è qualcosa che non va no perché grazie
alla nostra individualità che ognuno di
noi può fare può dare il proprio
contributo perché tutti assieme
arriviamo a questo possiamo arrivare a
questo scopo
perché solamente accettando e qui uso
prima Ho usato la parola presente no che
oggi usiamo tutti accettazione anche
oggi la usiamo tutti però ci sta un po'
sulle scatole No Cosa vuol dire
accettare una delle risposte se noi
Impariamo ad accettare l'impermanenza
dell'esperienza ci possiamo rendere
conto del dono più grande che sia stato
fatto questo dono eterno che è la vita e
questo è il nostro unico scopo
e Se trovate qualcosa di più Limitless
di questo
fatemelo sapere adesso Fermi fermi Se vi
va non so se me lo merito l'applauso ma
mi è venuta questa idea invece Siccome
dobbiamo
rispettare i tempi Invece di usare i 30
secondi per l'applauso Se vi va Io me ne
vado in silenzio voi chiudete gli occhi
prendete le mani giunte questa posizione
si chiama nascara ma è una tradizione
dello Yoga qui la facciamo in pochi
secondi Mettete le mani sul cuore
chiudete gli occhi e Provate a sentire
come quello che batte dentro ognuno di
voi è esattamente la stessa cosa per
tutti
vi ringrazio